[Music]
when you play the game of Thrones you
win will you die
[Music]
[Music]
one wall of the buses and it is here
Danny tell me Lauren that music you
don't win you die this is Game of
Thrones I'm so excited oh my god I'm so
excited okay so guys what you just
watched was a little teaser just
released now granted it features old
footage but what we now know is we are
officially less than 200 days away and
that sounds like a lot but I'm gonna
make the moment we've been waiting for
the final season of Game of Thrones HBO
has revealed we will get an April and
they just keep teasing us as little bits
of information for season eight we have
to wait till April to find out that's
what we know how fitting that this
dropped on the day that you're here
because you recently just binge watch
the entire series
I felt I felt that I was missing out on
a cultural that's how I feel well
you should do what I do which is watch
the entire series in one week don't
sleep and before you know it you're
talking to dragons that aren't even
there well tell me a color mean though
because unfortunately there was no new
footage in this teaser but there's a lot
of fan theories out here for all those
obsessive Game of Thrones fans about
what we could expect in this last season
like should we break it down for the
people let's break it down okay guys so
this is the question by the way let us
know what you think because while that
was old footage it was cut a certain way
certain scenes are shown certain lines
are increased Easter eggs a little bit
possibility there lose one fan theory
I'm sorry you haven't watched the show
yet it's okay I'm spoiler alert spoiler
alert Jon Snow is so heavily featured in
that trailer footage that people are
wondering does this mean jon snow dies
in the very end I mean it has happened
before though right he's died before he
casually came back to life as only John
snow can do I have to say I have I
talked to Peter Dinklage on a carpet
recently
nischelle Turner talked to some of the
cast on another carpet right after the
Emmys and they said look this show ends
brilliantly and ends emotionally that
makes me think we have to get major
deaths and Game of Thrones has always
given us major death I mean could it be
that maybe even more than Jon Snow do I
think we're going to see some serious
character elimination situation right
right right right right oh you know
know that they don't have to worry too
much about disappointing fans because
they've got so many prequels and other
spin-off shows in the work or explan
they know they're gonna give us more
that we don't have to worry so hopefully
more Jon Snow though he is fine he's
easy on the eyes Lauren
that's why I'll watch great Jason Momoa
was what might lure way sir mm-hmm next
up okay Jon Snow and Daenerys are not
shown much together so will we find out
about their true family lineage I'm not
gonna say too much about that here
because I don't want to spoil it for you
to talk about but there have been a lot
of questions what is their real
connection to each other especially
after last season's finale guys please
tweet us at ET now and let us know what
you think and by the way I do want to
tease easy online we have just put up an
interview with one of the directors from
the final season and he gives some TZ
tidbits so go there and read through our
interview with him it was not on camera
phone or interview some great quotes
from him another theory Cersei utters
her famous line you win or you die will
she get what's coming to her will she
die today that's the woman the pixi
right yeah like now well now yes yeah
that's her there's the thing no matter
what you want to say about this villain
she is a powerful character I think she
either I gotta say I think she's gonna
die too I do I think she's got and I
think it's gonna be an emotional death
okay okay yeah well aren't they all
because I've seen people you're rooting
for them I've seen you when you come
back from those binge watching sessions
you know puffy eyes a lot gone ah she's
filling the themes guys don't like it
when the hot guys die well always the
last one and this is so interesting guys
all series long even if you don't know
Game of Thrones you know the White
Walkers they're the question it's sort
of undead creatures that the people
fight the night king is shown in the
final shot of this new teaser footage we
have footage of him so he's shown Jon
Snow is shown will this be the final
battle him versus Jon Snow what we do
know is we are going to get an epic
battle scene production shot one scene
that took 55 days to film everybody at
55 days yes that's a long time that's
what
been waiting so long right for this
final season and they pushed it back
when I talked to Peter Dinklage he told
me that the way he thinks the show ends
is brilliant he says the bet the best
writers and they've done their best work
and the other cast members said they
think it's their favorite season ever
what did Peter say about his character
did he do a tease about what's gonna
happen he said he loved the way that it
is
he was like you guys are with this final
season he said you're in for it of
course we are
of death start binging it I have until
April 2019 for the final season
Cassie also doesn't watch it we're gonna
watch it together so we have someone to
talk to about it it's happening Game of
Thrones I will be on board perfect and I
can finally talk about all these
spoilers that your years back I love it
tardy for the party
[Music]
[Applause]